right we are now on day seven of the
controversy that is swirling around the
confirmation of Judge Brett Kavanaugh a
professor from Northern California named
professor Christine Ford is accusing
judge Kavanaugh of sexual misconduct
from when they were both in high school
1982 I have said many many times on this
program these allegations must be taken
seriously Senate Republicans are doing
just that tonight
they have delayed this week's
confirmation vote they have reopened the
hearings they have invited professor
Ford to tell her story before the
committee open or close the recession
they have reached out by phone by email
and more for background they are
handling this with the utmost care and
professionalism as they should and the
Senate Judiciary Committee has even
offered to fly their staff anywhere in
the United States to meet with Professor
Ford for a private interview in a Monday
professor Ford's attorney told fake News
CNN that her client would testify under
oath that she wanted to tell her story
publicly we have the videotape
take a look will your client Christine
Ford be willing to testify in public to
the Judiciary Committee the answer is
yes but here we are two days later
professor Ford is refusing even an
invitation to testify she now is
demanding through a lawyer she wants a
full FBI investigation into her claims
first and of course the US Senate they
don't control the FBI or what they
choose to investigate advise and consent
it is the constitutional role of the
United States Senate not the FBI also we
know the FBI has stated publicly the
allegation does not involve any federal
crime now the Senate can only perform
their own probe and unfortunately they
are now tonight being stonewalled
politics is in play and as of tonight
Dianne Feinstein she will not even show
Senate Republicans on the committee the
full unredacted letter that Professor
Ford sent to Democrats when she first
made her allegations in July and now
according to the Judiciary
Committee Chairman Charles Grassley the
letter to Ford's attorneys the committee
they're having a hard time reaching Ford
quote committee staff has attempted to
contact you directly by phone email
several times to schedule a call at a
convenient time for you and your client
we thus far have not heard back from you
with regard to that request and
Grassley's letter also reiterated the
invitation to appear before Congress
quote you have stated repeatedly the dr.
Ford wants to tell her story I sincerely
hope that dr. Ford will accept my
invitation to do so either privately or
publicly on Monday and despite every
effort from Republicans to accommodate
Professor Ford which i think is the
right thing to do
her attorney is calling Monday's hearing
quote not fair nor in good faith and
earlier today Senator John Kennedy
expressed his frustration watch this
we've done everything we can to try to
accommodate dr. Ford the she either her
or her lawyers keep moving the goalposts
which is a little frustrating and
Senator Susan Collins of Maine who I
don't always agree with she is saying
that it's not fair for either professor
Ford not to testify on Monday she said
it's not fair to either side take a
listen
I think it's not fair to judge Cavanaugh
for her not to come forward and testify
both of them need to testify under oath
next Monday before the Judiciary
Committee now senator Collins is right
it is so important to know the Senators
time frame is identical to the time
frame the Joe Biden set up when the left
did this to Clarence Thomas it's
important that we hear from Professor
Ford but also judge Cavanaugh deserves
the presumption of innocence and by the
way considering it was 36 years ago well
we have 36 years of his life and people
should be able to testify about his
treatment of women over nearly four
decades classmate classmates colleagues
ex-girl
female law clerks any of the 65 women
who signed the letter supporting his
outstanding character people that knew
him back in 1982 it's important that
America get this right this is something
the president rightly emphasized earlier
today take a listen
I really would want to see what she has
to say but I want to give it all the
time they need they've already given it
time they've delayed a major hearing
there's no more just a back look when I
first decided to run everybody said the
single most important thing you do is
the Supreme Court justice okay we've all
heard that many times about a president
I would say this I think he's an
extraordinary man I think he's a man of
great intellect as I've been telling you
and he's has an unblemished record this
is a very tough thing for him and his
family
and we want to get it over with at the
same time we want to give tremendous
amounts of time if she shows up that
would be wonderful
if she doesn't show up that would be
unfortunate now like every American
Judge Cavanaugh deserves the presumption
of innocence this is constitutional
right this is not a game sadly it's
obvious tonight the left is playing
politics trying to derail Cavanaugh's
nomination even if it means unfairly
impugning his character forever rushing
to judgment
watch this well it's definitely
attempted rape but III don't see it any
other way
I think it's appalling and I'm totally
disappointed that all these people who
have come forward to say we should hear
from her and now that she's expecting a
modicum of fairness so she's not
revitalized or now saying well she
doesn't want to testify we should just
go ahead that is additional callousness
from my colleagues that I am totally
appalled by when I see with what the
Republicans are doing today you know
yesterday they seemed a little tentative
and nervous and today and insisting and
in a bullying manner that dr. Ford
proceed with the hearing on Monday I
think they're trying to scare her
well I think what the Republicans doing
is outrageous they are creating a false
choice they are trying to bully her into
testifying on Monday before a full FBI
background check is completed I think
that she is the one who is taking
tremendous tremendous risk and coming
forward and I think she's saying let me
just have a fair shot at this don't put
me in front of a bunch of men on the
Judiciary Committee who have already
predetermined what the outcome should be
that would be the left people said from
day one Chuck Schumer said from day one
he will both stop him with it whatever
needs to happen you know so the
so-called least funny comedian on
television joyless Behar she even took
it a step further this is really
dangerous
take a listen this is what I grew up
with that men are supposed to protect
you to from these predatory male
[Applause]
these people in Congress right now in
that Senate Judiciary Committee these
white men old by the way I'm not
protecting women they're protecting a
man who is probably guilty if you're not
judge Kavanagh takes a lie detector test
yeah prove it the way she did and the
way I need a hill did that they were not
lying let's see that from you and the
Riu account yeah no presumption of
innocence this is sad
and sadly Democrats everywhere are
echoing what you just heard from joyless
Behar take a listen this woman is to be
believed and you can believe dr. Ford
this was attempted rape and this is a
woman who exhibits dr. Ford courage but
the classic signs of post-traumatic
stress I believe her listen first of all
anybody who comes forward at this point
to be prepared to testify in the United
States Senate against someone who's
being nominated to one of the most
powerful positions in the United States
government that takes an extraordinary
amount of courage not only do women like
dr. Ford who bravely comes forward need
to be heard but they need to be believed
they need to be believed let me just say
right at the outset I believe dr. Ford I
believe the survivor here there's every
reason to believe her she has come
forward courageously and bravely does
anyone give the chance that maybe you
can believe Judge Cavanaugh the
Constitution be damned and we just lock
him up throw away the key from what
happened in 1982 one person all these
other people say just the opposite about
about judge Kavanagh
how about due process how about
listening to both sides this is what
Democrats are willing to do sadly
tonight if it means obstructing the
nomination of Judge Cavanaugh and his
children are watching in case you're
interested
and his wife in fact Democrats they
don't even want a serious investigation
into these allegations you just heard
what Senate
Gillibrand just said they just want
Kavanagh block whatever it takes
Kirsten Gillibrand herself you're not
even interested in a hearing from
Kavanagh next week don't even want to
hear what he has to say
take a listen it's a sham hearing and I
don't think she should participate in it
so she and the rest of her Democratic
colleagues have ulterior motives now
it's starting to backfire Americans are
catching on
they know that Dianne Feinstein sat on
Ford's accusations for weeks this is
back in July she had this information
she never asked Cavanaugh about it
during many private meetings with him
during his public testimony written
questions over 1,300 questions not one
about this but they knew about it now
all of a sudden according to Dianne
Feinstein senator Gillibrand other
Democrats this is so pressing
Cavanaugh's confirmation must be
derailed regardless of whether or not
the accuser ever even comes forward and
tells her story in a letter to senator
Feinstein today Judiciary Chairman Chuck
Grassley he summed up the situation best
he said sexual assault allegation should
not be deployed strategically for
political gain
he's right and what we're seeing right
now is just another sad chapter in what
is sadly the Democrats predictable
playbook we see it every election year -
and for years Republicans are racist
sexist misogynistic homophobic
xenophobic Islamophobic they want dirty
air and water they want to kill children
and they want Paul Ryan look-alikes to
throw granny over the cliff you see it
every election season and also during
every confirmation hearing just like you
are seeing now smears slander lies
character assassination no due process
no presumption of innocence conviction
by allegation and of course we have
every reason to be skeptical tonight
this is the same party of keith Ellison
see that guy right there well he just
got his party's nomination to run for
the Attorney General in the great state
of Minnesota
all while this is happening currently
his ex-girlfriend is accusing him
of domestic physical and emotional abuse
she tweeted this week that the
Democratic Party did not believe her
claims despite what is out there
including a doctor's report that she had
told in 2017 indicating abuse instead
she tweeted the DNC quote smeared
threatened and isolated her so where are
these same Democratic senators demanding
FBI investigations into him this is not
36 years ago this is today this is the
same Democratic Party of senator sherrod
Brown he walks the halls of Congress
despite domestic abuse accusations made
by his ex-wife for some reason she
politically supports him but the record
is the record and don't forget professor
Ford's attorney we cannot ignore her
record
Debra Katz has a longtime Democratic
activists she's donated tens of
thousands of dollars to Democrats but
more importantly her track record in
previous cases on issues of sexual
misconduct allegations when they were
made well let's let's show you what see
said about Paula Jones Paula Jones suit
is very very weak she's alleged one
incident that took place in a hotel room
that buy her testimony lasted 10 to 12
minutes
she suffered no repercussions in the
workplace the allegation was that Bill
Clinton pulled down his pants and told
her to perform a sex act and then she
said of Jones's accusation quote clearly
a one-time incident that took place in
10 to 12 minutes she was not forced to
have sex she left on her own volition
the courts increasingly are finding that
this is not enough to create a sexually
hostile work environment on top of that
cats also defended creepy senator Al
Franken quote context is relevant he did
not do this as a member of the Senate he
did this in his capacity of someone who
was still functioning as an entertainer
but he was a senator at the time he did
it now this is highly bitterly partisan
an attorney who clearly obviously has
inconsistent views on this
EPIK to advance a political agenda it's
sad and of course no democrats ever
demanded an FBI investigation and paul
jones she won a settlement by the way of
$850,000 Juanita Broderick accused Bill
Clinton of rape Kathleen Willey accused
Bill Clinton of groping grabbing
fondling
touching against her will you have many
of these same senators that are there
today all sanctimonious rushing to
judgment selectively moral outrage
tonight they lived on all things Clinton
women that were smeared slandered by the
Clinton machine selectively moral
outrage
obviously pure politics and as you can
see we have every reason to be skeptical
about the Democrats otherwise they'd be
saying the same things about keith
ellison otherwise they'd be saying okay
where's the FBI investigation in juanita
Broderick's charges they're playing
politics with the Cavanaugh nomination
they're playing politics with government
accountability on top of that you know
the news tonight we told you Monday
President Trump ordered the Department
of Justice to declassify and release
unredacted important documents pages 10
through 12 17 through 34 of the final
FISA renewal application on Carter page
all FBI reports on bruce ors russia
interviews with Christopher Steele all
reports on Carter page interviews
thousands of struck page tax and Comey
McCabe and or and steel and other people
that are involved in this president is
the commander-in-chief he's also the
leader of the executive branch of
government co-equal branches of
government separation of powers he has
the clear constitutional authority in
the Constitution to declassify
information article 2 section 1 of our
Constitution reads quote the executive
power shall be vested in a president of
the United States of America the DOJ and
the FBI are under the president's
executive power he is in charge and
constitutionally he alone can determine
the issue of classification not redact
acting things according to the Supreme
Court Navy V Eagan quote the authority
to classify and control access to
information bearing on national security
and to determine flows primarily from
this constitutional investment of the
power of the president both presidents
Barack Obama Bill Clinton used their
authority to declassify information
Obama Declassified hundreds of CIA
records in 2015 former President Clinton
Declassified thousands of confidential
documents around in the military but
according to top Democrats tonight
President Trump has no authority to
declassify these important FISA related
documents we got shifty shift is calling
it an abuse of power that it will put
the country at risk
he joined three other Democrats
demanding to be briefed on the
declassification before anything is
released to the public John Brennan and
others even calling on bureaucrats to
defy the rule of law the clear intent of
the Constitution and disobey a
president's direct executive order on
this and not release the documents that
will precipitate a massive
constitutional crisis as they try to
take power constitutionally away from
your elected president this is
extraordinarily dangerous watch this
it's a terrible precedent to have a
president trying to make his own
personal defense by playing with
intelligence this is quite Mallis of the
President to selectively declassify you
know he's only putting forward to the
American people what he believes helps
him completely and recklessly risking
sources and methods who could be put at
risk and have their lives at risk of
array director of FBI and Dan Costa
rector of National Intelligence as well
as rod Rosenstein who is overseeing this
investigation should push back against
any directive that is going to have
negative impact on our capabilities as
well as the investigation so I think
that should continue to push push push
if mr. Trump in the White House does not
relent well then I think they have some
decisions to make whether or not they're
going to just not follow that direction
and be fired or to resign but if they
really believe that this is going to
have
serious impact on our national security
law enforcement and judicial process
they have an obligation since they took
an oath of office to the Constitution
United States not to mr. Trump what
you're witnessing here this is why it's
so dangerous deep state operatives
they're trying to precipitate a
constitutional crisis in the country
because they don't want to be exposed
meanwhile one former corrupt officials
now facing a grand jury investigation
former deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
always got a new book out in December
and here's the title the threat how the
FBI protects America in the age of
terror and trauma oh that means to defy
the will of the American people abuse
power use the tools of intelligence
against the American people
we have long told you your federal
bureaucracy was biased corrupt only at
the highest levels not rank and file a
former deputy at the FBI deputy director
this is the perfect embodiment of this
fact they literally will precipitate a
constitutional crisis and try and defy
the constitutional authority that is so
clear for the president and the
executive branch now look if we want the
deep state developments to continue you
got to focus on this election 48 days
from tonight all we have until this
crucial the most important midterms in
our life there is a glimmer of hope
tonight new poll only a 4% ballot gap in
generic ballot
earlier this week in Texas of specials
say state Senate election Republican
beat a Democrat in that district for the
first time in 139 years Ted Cruz is now
up by 9 points and the latest polling /
139 years
look I'm not confident tonight 48 days
out the Republicans will keep the house
and I'm sure that I'm not sure they'll
hold the Senate I'll have a crystal ball
we cannot be complacent the only way
that will turn is if you take your
responsibility to vote seriously you
want the Trump agenda to continue you
like the extra money in your paycheck is
America's economy better off than it was
two years ago are we more secure tonight
as a country do you want the president
you elected to continue on the path to
keeping his promises for a better
economy
The Forgotten men and women that will
left behind in the Obama years 13
million more people on food stamps 8
million more on power in poverty 48 days
you decide you get to vote you have the
power you get to stop this insanity of
the left I hope you're energized